okay so start with the midfoot and then
put balance
that's where your weight sets
your knees are going out
the body is expanding
and then you add
the energy
from the sword onto that vector
so if i have this this midfoot vector
and i keep my balance in that state i
add the sword you're gonna go forward
okay right
very good
as you add
energy to the front of your body so
this is one
balance point
and you're going to have to find a new
one
for the sword
so it's dynamic with projector and as
you bring this up
it's going to change because that energy
value is changing you see so if i stay
here
and i start to bring this sword up
it's getting longer as my arms are
getting longer do you see that and it's
going to pull me forward
you guys understand so you can't just
stand worrying about where you want to
stand the whole time
even though my body's not moving
because i've tasked myself with the
mid-foot vector
is quite dynamic
as it moves up
with foot and foot and equipment foot
and putting the foot in the foot has to
stay
each one has to take so i have mid-foot
vector here
and as i leave it there
and this thing starts to come back
it's going to
start to bring me back
okay
so you're staying here not realizing
that your body's going backwards
because the energy value of the sword is
moving as it goes through itself
so
pushing it forward
i'll see your breath lie today
so
here i have my foot back vector and i
inhale
and it changes it too okay
see if you're seeing your weight go toes
heels toes heels that's because you're
not adapting for every those ever
changing energy values okay
so
it's one thing to do up and down when
you're keeping the same energy value but
for what your breath is adding
and if you hold your breath which is not
uncommon
you're gonna do it
but it's quite dynamic
so let that mid-foot vector cover
okay
slow down the sword like that so it
gives you time to adjust
okay
so the first thing you want to get is
that mid-foot vector
all energies
all mass has energy got all energy
all movement movement has energy all
energy goes into that mid foot into the
ground
but you're not just standing i can stand
on that mid foot like this you see with
my legs extended stuff
we're going to use that line
energetically but actually we're going
to use the energy of the ground
okay and i can't do that like this
knees are in alignment with my feet
energy is going out on my legs so my
knees are not coming
in
nor my thighs boom everything is in
alignment
expanding out okay
um
that's what the exercise is doing
element number one it's not
uh exercising your
uh
legs it's not a quadricep exercise you
would do lifts for that okay
so
this is going to take you out of
that other exercise
because this posture is not going to
help me use the earth energy
it's likewise
this thing
you see that wait
what movie makers think is samurai
posture
okay
get rid of that
flat
okay
and also this thing
this is not right on the head
okay
the chin is slightly down
not that not the top of your head
is not the top of your posture boom
with the crown of your head in alignment
with your spine and that's going to make
your chin go slightly down
running
though if he's going to
i'm going to do different things
and he's going to do this i can
he will not be able to
brace him to the ground ok
but if you get the other posture and you
can push and go ahead and you just push
it into the ground
okay normally you would go where's my
uh
bracing angle you don't you don't need
the bracing angle because he's just
pushing all that energy that's going
down okay so
no like that
okay
uh and no super deep and making a
quadricep exercise so
flat
and that's going to require your pelvis
to go the opposite way
then
samurai
champloo wants it okay boom this way
no
here
okay
this is ready
then you're gonna get it
okay let's try it again fix your body
can't just do whatever with your body go
okay that was all the internal part of
the external external part okay
uh the internal part that's the harm
part right i'm gonna use that to get
this okay
so as i
move the sword from its resting position
you can feel
as i move it upward
there's the gravitational energy
it doesn't want to go you know that's
that energy
that gravitational energy
i send
down in through my body down onto that
ground vector okay it's no different
than his
transversing energy that's coming this
way it goes into the ground and that's
what goes back out to him
he goes oh
same thing i'm just using gravity now
okay
so
i'm going to take that energy home goes
into the
up
so there's a kind of
inward
pulling
of the internal aspect
and when i go back down
you're gonna see
there's an accelerating of that energy
or a communing with the gravitational
pull
and now my external is going to be
that
pushing okay
[Music]
there's the ip4 and the cube okay so i'm
just doing it with the sword
that means
that my four corners are going to remain
in place
and my center is going to remain
pressurized okay i can't do it like this
you see how
okay
feel that that goes in through your body
down to the ground
and then
back down
so on this side
i think on the tip
and on this side
on the suitcase
and it's exactly this feeling
[Music]
exactly the same okay
let's try to
now
we're going to
work with
transferring that
midfoot vector and that energy
from
the front foot
to the back
same thing
no
here
release the lower legs
he's gonna i'm gonna go into my yin
phase
and he's gonna hit the energy of the
planet he would hit the energy behind it
on the push
push and it doesn't matter and then
if uh
when i go forward
this is not my ground vector and if he
pulls it will go into that
in this other way he's pulling this
other way at this
oh and moment be in the pool stage so
what i what i want to point out there
this is very common that most people go
you see this
that's the head of the ground vector and
when he pulls i'm not going to be able
to hold it can't ground that energy okay
so
mid foot
not here this is ruining your knees
so young face on this foot
long face on this foot knees to toes
same thing center is locked in expanding
pressure
push earth
receive
receive push
receive push okay let's try all right
i'm going to
walk into that
left on me
keep my hips still
stink that foot up
don't keep turning your hips
shift and your hips stay still and sneak
everything stays still and because all
weight was on this foot this foot can
slip up you see without any obvious
turning
boom ground the front foot around the
front flip and he comes over here
all right and he's pulling he's gonna
just hit the ground foot i leave that
everything where it is and i sneak that
foot up like that okay let's try that
just
shift onto that and this sneaks in see
no movement okay if i didn't have mine
if i didn't have my husband
step into it shift
you see you can't see where that flip
went okay
you got that i'm just untucking it so
you can see my feet what i do
so i step in
oh
round that foot as if you had to pull
it
and bring that foot in
now i'm going to do that weight shift
again
back to this way okay and you're gonna
see
my body is starting to move over here
you see it moved ever so slightly to the
right
so
get in that
position so over here when i shift my
weight it's starting to move to the
right okay
again over here
young face go to the young face on the
other foot
here
and the yang phase is the beginning of
the yid phase you see the end of the
young phase is the beginning of the yin
phase that means
uh as i have the line boom this is what
allows me to turn so
whoa
down and now i can turn on that foot now
my head will move further to the right
so let's move it to the right and i add
the turn and it's going further to the
right again ever so slightly
boom
waits on this foot and i turn on that
foot okay
boom
oh
where are you turning on the midfoot
it's not that i'm pushing with my heel
whoa
hips
okay let's get that torque going go just
get to where we were
and what's happening
is i'm starting to go around this
i'm axle
a void right here at my spine level okay
so this has to be in front of me but
it's fine okay
i'm going around going around the weapon
going
see that
i'm starting to move towards the right
you see that then i turn
and i'm on the right
side
okay
um
this is a marshall
angle deviation
let's let's say you could still work for
a second uh
the guy's sword is coming down on this
spine this vector
it's coming down right here
i'm still on the line
we're still on the line
i actually stayed on the line or i go
one i'm still on the line you see
half of me still over here
and then
now i cut off
that requires a lot of time
time
makes it impractical it's no different
and he's throwing his jab and i'm
expecting these kind of clues
okay do you get it
uh this is enough
that's enough it goes fast
that's enough that's all i need so i'm
not asking for much
it makes it more practical okay
so in this drill
you'll have that weapon you got to put
it really really close to you because
it's your spine that you're doing this
is trying to cut down your center line
right so your weight was on the front
it starts to move
around the weapon and you're on the
other side
okay
let's try that bushido
go
okay
start to turn
turn
everything
turn everything i'm picking up my foot
to let you know i'm not
pushing off that foot okay weight is
over here this foot is
not part of the turn that would be
double pivot and that would mean weight
was not all the way over here you get
that you can push off there you had some
weight on that foot okay and that would
mean you're still on the line of attack
okay
so all weight goes over and you turn
your body turn your body and this foot
now is free
to
just readjust
and gather a new angle of tap here
behind okay
it's not part of your deviation meaning
i'm still on the line
and then i deviated the deviation
already happened so
we'll adjust new angle over time all
weight is still on this foot okay
you're getting
you're gonna
okay punch make it
real tight
don't be square
hip all the way because you're in this
young phase and my four corners are tied
to the young face this is a disconnect
you see
okay
try it
in
shift
shift uh it's very common
go back to there you can see my feet
very very common
that you shift here
and you you know it's true
this this turning on one foot is
difficult that's right now we're only
probably one of you is able to actually
move forward okay
so
you're gonna step
and you have this
goofy thing
okay
this is biomechanically unsound
because my foot
is pulling on the tendons across my knee
here you see and now i'm out of
four corner alignment
my knee is not in alignment with my hip
it's outside you see
this is where i was supposed to be
uh
and then our master does it in our
master our master meaning our master
couldn't turn
okay
and now this is what we started doing
when i was supposed to not be in this
way
but in this way
you see that difference
so if anything minimum this foot is
straight to the line of attack
if it was going to be at any angle it
would be it boom so you could drive that
hip in more you see that
it would not be here and i'm trying to
drive that hip in so you can't drive
that headpin so you're back here
okay
do you get that
so you can't
you can't break the laws of the internal
aspects
so that foot has to turn so that my knee
stays in alignment so that my hip stays
in alignment so that my shoulder stays
in alignment can't be going out you're
going to hurt yourself too
another common mistake
is if if i shifted my weight here
and i turned my weight i'm going to go
really slow so you can see and i turn my
weight you see
and i'm supposed to stay in the young
phase then my head should not travel
back you see that
so that that was that was the whole all
the deviation that i think said not here
if you find that your head is now
traveling back
you weren't staying in the young faces
try to leave it
right on that foot okay try it again
okay so uh the
embryonic drill number one this is not
the technique because the timing is
totally different
in application okay so although he has a
sword in his hand it is not a cut
it's a
uh training vector i use his training
vector okay
so uh i'm going to start
in that position so
uh
how did i get there well i got there
when i took the step and i sucked that
foot in without changing anything
and i started up here okay
got it but we're just gonna start from
up there so
uh say aloud where is my weight
[Music]
right not in not in the middle of my two
feet it's a it's a fake it's a fake okay
um
so he's gonna now put his
sword on my wrist the cutting portion of
his sword
i'm going to shift my weight onto the
other foot and start the turn and you
see how i'm moving around that angle you
see
okay and his sword tip is now hitting
that void of the joke
not not hitting me anymore
okay not hitting me not on the line of
attack
and going around where his sword would
have dropped okay
uh
now what i'm going to do
is yawn
down
okay
we're going to take that left hand off
in this drill just to help you out okay
boom
down
you can see that uh my weight is on that
weapon
let's undo a lot of this
see it got lighter
boom
got lighter do you see
put your weight into your hand
where's my weight on my front foot
on that midfoot don't go over
okay
so same thing jimmy oh
and he would be pulling he's just
pulling that ground vector right there
okay try it again
okay so we got there
oh he's gonna go i'm gonna go
and i'm going to come down his sword
that's my vector that's why it's a
training video i'm going to come down
his sword
down into the tuba
and attack his center so the energy
leave your energy so that i can
demonstrate this the energy is going
into his center it's not coming
on top of this okay
i'm not aiming for that
meaning i'm not moving my sword how it
goes to do that
it's all in it's set up already
this hand can just turn
and go straight down as i go through the
rest of
the geometry
itself is the aiming
home
right and so
this down cut
of shogun subaru
i'm on top of the sword remember on the
sukkah boom down my arms are down here
all i've done is change my feet
and change which foot
is boom
doing that drop do you see so this is
going to be wrong i'm not doing it
this is wrong
and
that's wrong
this sword is supposed to be
onto that midfoot the energy of the
downwardness
boom goes onto the midfoot vector okay
whom and now energy
is on that right foot
flying down
okay so look where this sword finishes
uh not over here not over here you start
missing
not only do you see you miss
you miss
it's
here
down okay
two hands now
straight down
don't let your head go back
because you miss
in place
[Music]
okay well let's try it
okay so this is a training drill and in
training you always exaggerate
you
exaggerate things to
lengthen
the cultivation process okay so uh for
example
um
this is lengthening
that yin yield you
when he did his jab
well that was the yin yield
do you see that
um
what do you see in people who can't even
heal this is what they do that's how
they think they're going to get out of
the way you see they're oh i'm moving
out of the way but it's not from the yin
spirit you see so they're running away
kind of thing they're not receiving it
so this is a you you can lengthen that
stuff do you see and the same thing uh
yeah you do what it doesn't matter okay
same thing with the uh length and the
ikea adhesion do you get it it's not
your it's not that
oh no we're never gonna do that
that this is a training
so uh it doesn't matter
uh if we go a little faster right
that little bit that brought him in do
you see that's the same thing just done
quickly
um
so this is lengthening prolonging
exaggerating
uh
putting energy onto the midfoot
emphasizing the weight dropping okay you
got that so
uh you can do kitty a tush
uh
that's killing a touch too
do you see
but
that's not the drill
okay
so
i'm exaggerating
everything
everything weight heavy weight heavy
down
all my weight there
uh
can't you come around and you'll see my
weight is in my hands
pick up my hands from the bottom of the
bow of my hands
oh you can go ahead and he's going to
feel all that weight he's not going to
get that thing down okay he can test the
tip too he tests the tip and same thing
he's not getting that thing up
over here
i did a kitty a tush boom up here and
it's just me
i'm trying to hold that down with my
wrist strength you see hold it we're
going to hold it we're going to
exaggerate
[Music]
you got the idea okay so we go
way down
wait into his center
not just on the suba
i'm in through his center because that's
going to be more resistance do you see
now i get to cultivate myself more
okay
let's try it again go uh the principle
of kimmy remains the same okay so he is
going to practice the technique
uh i'm very alive i'm very dynamic i'm a
vessel i'm ready to receive okay
i'm going to yin yield to this thing i'm
not going to run away from it and i'm
not gonna fight it okay so when we're
here
and he goes
i don't take it in my shoulders do you
see
he's attacking my center so my center
moves
okay
he goes
if you pay attention the angle of his
sword is displacing my sword to the
right
so
i make sure my sword does not go to the
left
and i make sure that my sword does not
stay still
i let him displace my sword
you can go harder
then if we if i keep my sword there and
i stay in my shoulders he's going to hit
your arms
you see
but
if you yield with his downward pressure
sure
if i start to yield and i start to
displace
my arms went on the other side of his
okay
um let's do it again and stay at the
last
position right
harness
stay there
and you can see
push down right let's do it again
his weight is on his hands
and it's on the tip then
okay that's what you want to experience
all right here we go pay attention
okay so this is a common
uh error
and the common error is from the
this is external
uh and in external applications go ahead
uh you have a lever
and then you have a
distillate
right and so who has the mechanical
advantage he does he does okay and as a
result you see your sword bounces off of
him it does not displace
immediately
you guys understand that so uh that has
to do with going back to this drill
first you got to find your ground vector
and then we moved on from there it's a
dynamic ground vector okay but i use
that all energy whatever movement matter
mass gravity all that goes down into the
earth and is what is rebounding either
in an uh energetic pathway towards my
person or an energetic pathway away from
my person do you see that and um when
i'm coming down that all that energy
bouncing off the earth in an energetic
pattern away from my person and that we
don't have we just swing in the sword
okay
um
in real you know if you're like oh real
kitty
yeah we're not going to do it
okay
we have to be able to displace it
um some other common
errors
is my sword is out of alignment
with my body do you see that i'm here
like that i know you all land
go down
pretend
okay and you're over here like this
dizzy you get that here is where your
power is and the internal aspects but
you had to change it okay
um
again another common one
is that you are retreating backwards
do you see and then you're not going to
miss
your power line is box here i didn't hit
the tuba do you see that
so you leave everything out there
to keep contact you see so you end up
down at the bottom
and you end up in something like this
i see there's no power there this is
where my internal aspects are
right
another one is habitual
uh
just mindlessness
is you get
these weird head tails
okay
uh
now
your head is part of your
ground factory do you understand so
watch all
the these
watch all these weird
head tails that you're doing
okay those are all incorrect
um
of course the bushido tencon is very
technical
we already discussed that virus and is
retreating
but some other ones are of course the
double pivoting
you see that
and equally wrong is doing elimi
tencon
there's no time and the bait does not
work this is a baiting drill okay
um
so pay attention to these very very very
very common mistakes out too far
out of alignment
head doing weird things
uh and then this
just your ishido tencon is not actually
a new shield
okay
okay so the question came up on uh
the deviation
of moving that foot in do you see uh
because usually we're like i only know
come on
and then if you watch my head it moves a
lot through space do you see that
um
and then it's not marshalled because i'm
just running away from that guy okay as
opposed to create a void around his line
of attack rotate around the line of
attack and boom attack on the other side
of the circle which is the art okay
this traversing through space is not the
arc okay
um
let's say
he's throwing a
series of one two combinations and i
pick up on it oh that dude likes a one
two
and he never comes in past that he goes
out he's just trying to knock me out
with that cross he he has a pattern you
wanna look for patterns in the opponents
because
people not trained far enough
use patterns okay and now you can use
their patterns against them you see
um so
let's say he keeps doing one two and
then oh and he keeps doing oh he went
back
you see he went back after that one and
i started keying in on that kind of
stuff right uh so i'm here boom he goes
back
back you see
and he feels safe as he's doing it okay
and so what i'm going to do
is let him feel safe for a while
do you get it so we're going to slow it
down so you can see this and i want you
to pay attention when my back foot
changes the depth of my stance you see
that so at first
i bait him with this
and then eventually
you see how that foot moves in
but to him when he's focusing up top he
doesn't see the back foot move in do you
see that so he's going
and i'm moving it in but my upper body
did not move at all you see that okay so
we go a little slow slower
i can now penetrate that thing coming
back because that's not was not my
actual stance anymore but he thought it
was my actual stance you see that um
that's very common you can do it too on
on and let's say he's way out there
right and i'm trying to throw some kicks
and he keeps moving back on me do you
get it
and he's always out of range of the kick
and i start leaving my upper body the
same somewhere hiding it my back foot
came in
now you can now
get the extra range you want to do so
there's a bait in there okay
um
and that's what
strategically is going on in that first
thing okay you're not sitting here
and then giving them all the advantage
and then
so fast i got out of the way of your
action which does not happen
you get it you cannot get out of the way
of someone's action
do you guys understand that so uh
because
the average human being
somewhere around three quarters of a
second to a quarter a
second and a half reactionary gap
okay
so uh
he has his hands
right here
he's gonna clap
he's gonna try to catch my hand before i
touch his chest
i i am gonna do that
you can have it
right
you're gonna every because he has that
processing time do you see do you got it
oh you could be pretty far away too
got it
okay uh so this makes no sense that i
give you a four foot knife
hey go i think i can beat your
reactionary time
do you understand like come on man
uh so you it's a bait bait he
sneaks and you're coming around
attacking around that uh line of attack
he said that foot has to come in
but your upper body has to remain in on
me
okay
and then you go around
the descending line of attack to attack
on the other side of the circle
okay